MICHAEL HANDLER: All right,
good afternoon everybody.
I'm ready to get started.
So this is a pretty
good turnout.
This is a little better than I
was expecting for a talk where
I'm not going to actually show
you any code or anything new
at the end of the second
day of the conference.
If I knew it was going to be
this good, I wouldn't have
bribed all of my coworkers
to show up.
But thank you very
much for coming.
So this in Life in App Engine
Production for Google IO 2011.
And we've got some hash tags up
here suggested if you want
to Twitter during the talk.
And we've got a very convenient
and memorable
feedback URL that you can visit
if you'd like to give us
feedback during the
talk or after.
And we'd very much appreciate
if you do that.
So I'm ready.
So let's get started.
So who am I?
I'm Michael Handler.
I'll be your cruise director
for this talk.
I'm the Tech Lead for the
App Engine SRE team.
I'm based out of
San Francisco.
I'll be co-presenting with my
first mate, Alan Green, also
from the App Engine SRE team.
He's based out of the
Sydney office.
And we've got the hash tags and
the feedback URL up there
again, just in case you missed
it in the last five minutes.
So everybody says we should
have a table of contents.
So I'm going to get through
this as quickly as I can.
So who am I, what do I do,
what do I do all day?
How does that affect
App Engine?
What has happened to App Engine
that we expected?
What's happened to App Engine
that we didn't expect?
What do we do to make App Engine
more reliable when
those things happen to us, both
the stuff we expected and
the stuff we didn't expect?
And based on all of that, if
you're building a production
system on App Engine or off site
of App Engine, what can
you do to make your application
more reliable?
And then, we've got a demo of
some monitoring technology
that we're really happy about
and that we're entering
Trusted Tester with.
So I've said SRE twice and
I haven't defined it.
So I should probably fix that.
So SRE is Site Reliability
Engineer.
So this is a program that
started in Google some number
of years ago, and here you
can see our mascot
with our logo on it.
We are concerned with the
lack of down time,
or rather, up time.
So Google Site Reliability
Engineering.
So we have a very simple mission
which is, Google
products need to be fast, they
need to be available.
Whenever you put google.com into
your browser, whenever
your website requests content
ads or whatever, that has to
happen, it has to happen all of
the time, 24 hours a day,
365 days a year, or 366,
just like that.
As fast as possible, so that
the users are happy.
So what we end up doing doesn't
show up in new product
releases, new SDKs, change
lists, et cetera.
A lot of the work that
we do is invisible.
And we wanted to say, we want
to get out there and let
people know that Google has
SRE teams because we want
people to know that we
exist because we do.
And for you to understand the
kind of work that we're doing,
both for you on App Engine and
for all other Google products.
So what happens when Google
products launch is that the
developers run them.
So they're spending all of their
time getting the product
stable and directing traffic
to it and saying, OK, let's
encourage people to use it.
Let's get out there and
advocate for it.
And then it gets a certain
level of stability and a
certain level of growth.
And we're saying, OK, wow.
People actually like this
product and want to use it.
And the developers are splitting
their time between
well, let's make the product
as stable as we can while
growing it and also adding
these new features.
And this doesn't end up
working out really
well that we found.
It's better if you can let
people focus on adding new
features and let other people
specialize on making it stable
for the existing users
and enabling growth.
And this is where the
SREs come in.
So we originally had SRE teams
docketed to Search and Ads.
You know, the original
core Google products.
That tells you how old this
program goes back.
Because the Search developers
and the Ads developers needed
to spend all of their time
adding the features and they
had lost scope of all the things
that we needed to do to
deal with the volume of Google
search queries that were
coming in every day.
So we're talking about App
Engine reliability.
And the SRE team, we're the
people that do that.
So you may sort of think, well,
what does that day look
like for us?
Well, we're sitting around and
then the alarm goes off and we
go, oh my God.
Something's wrong.
We all pile out, we fix the
problem, put the fire out,
everybody's back and happy in
doing what they're doing, and
we go back into the fire house
and we sit around, play cards,
and wait till the alarm
goes off again.
So if you've been App Engine
for a long time and we had
some instability problems in
the past, you might think a
little differently of us.
You might say, like, wow,
there's a reliability team?
They should take off their clown
noses and they should
get back to work.
But the reality of this is
actually a little different.
Which is to say that we're
technical professionals, we're
engineers, and we look at
this from an engineering
perspective.
We certainly respond with a
priority when there's a
problem, but what we need to do
in addition to fixing it,
is make sure that it doesn't
happen again.
It's not just enough to
do crisis response.
You actually have to do full
engineering to understand the
problems to understand
what's going on.
What we end up spending most of
our time doing is managing
complexity.
You've all designed and
architected systems, and
you've put diagrams up there.
And they're beautiful and simple
and you go, wow, this
is fantastic.
It's going to work.
And that diagram never
survives first
contact with the enemy.
And that's even more true at
Google than it is outside at
smaller scale.
So all of these things, your
perfect plan gets overridden
by reality.
So where does that complexity
come from?
Well, we all run on computers
and we all know that computers
are very reliable things that
never do anything that is at
all mysterious or that
you don't expect.
That might actually be slightly
true when they're
standing alone, but we put
them in datacenters and
they're all interconnected
between each other.
And a computer that was having
a great time just sort of
doing it's thing, now it's
getting bothered by its
neighbor down the row and
it's not as reliable
as it used to be.
It's asking it to do things,
crazy things are happening,
traffic patterns are going on.
It's just confusing.
And then, we make the situation
worse because we've
got datacenters every where
all around the world.
And they're all interconnected
at high speed, and this means
that not only can your nice,
reliable computer be bothered
by a computer near it, it can
be bothered by a computer
halfway around the world.
We've got the infrastructure,
the support infrastructure.
That if you built this global
network of applications,
servers, datacenters, and all
of these other things, you
need a bunch of support
infrastructure.
I'm going to touch on exactly
what that looks like in a
little bit.
And then, you've got the traffic
coming from the users.
More traffic then you could
ever expect that you could
ever deal, that you ever thought
that you would deal.
And it comes every day without
fail with peaks and valleys
and you have to be ready.
You know, whatever happens
with you today at peak
traffic, if you started having
problems, it's going to happen
to you just as badly tomorrow
and you need to be ready to
deal with it.
And we haven't gone into the
circumstances of random chance.
We have a lot of computers.
We have a lot of datacenters.
We have a lot of complicated
systems. They all interact
with each other and each one of
those systems, every day,
is a chance for the universe
to roll the dice and say,
maybe something weird is
going to happen to you.
So you have to be ready for
these kind of things as well.
So I had a very simple balancing
act over here.
So we've got stability on one
side and over here we've got
the new features that the
developers are carefully
stacking on.
And we'll just balance
this out.
It's not that simple.
It's not that simple on the
reliability side at all.
So this is a quote from Leslie
Lamport, a computer scientist
who invented the Paxos
distributed consensus algorithm.
We use this inside
App Engine on the
high replication datastore.
"A distributed system is one
in which the failure of a
computer you didn't even know
existed can render your own
computer unusable." And that's
more or less, a description of
my day every day.
Which is to say that
there are--
we've got the Rumsfeld
reference up here.
There are unknown unknowns.
I come to work and something
weird has happened.
It might be from a computer
I've heard of.
It might not.
And if it's one I've heard of,
I probably know what to do.
If it's one I've never heard
of before, I need to figure
out quickly, restore everything
to service, and
then go on making sure that
that doesn't happen again.
So we're talking about
life in production.
And that's the Google production
environment.
And what does that look like?
Where can I get one of these
fantastic hard hats and ear
protection for my
day-to-day job?
So App Engine's a cloud
computing environment.
You all know this.
And Google has a cloud computing
environment.
We don't have a dedicated
datacenter for App Engine.
We don't have a dedicated set
of machines for App Engine.
We run App Engine inside the
same cloud computing
environment that Google does.
And so there's all of these
layers of infrastructure
inside Google's cloud computing
environment.
You've got the part the
environment itself, you've got
lock services, storage
services, monitoring,
configuration and reporting,
binary
packages, and there's like--
I ran out of space before I
could list all the ones that I
thought were really important.
I know there are computers and
they need power , networking,
and cooling if they're going to
operate, if they're going
to be at all useful to us.
So it's interesting that we find
ourselves somewhat in the
same situation that our
customers do in terms of
running App Engine.
So you come to us and say, well,
we want you to run this
application for us.
And we say, that's fantastic.
We'll totally do that.
But we don't run all of that,
all of those things that I
just mentioned, ourselves.
We can't.
There's not enough of us and the
specialization that would
be required for us to run
every part of the
infrastructure all the way down
to the computers would be
astronomical.
We would need a huge team of
people, and we probably
wouldn't be consistently good
at running all parts of it.
So in the same way that you
depend on us, we depend on
further down the stack, a bunch
of people, a bunch of
SREs running the storage
surface, the lock service, the
cloud computing environment,
all the way down to
datacenters and hardware
ops who keep
on running the machines.
Now, we can't operate with them
on a handshake basis in
the same way that we can't
operate with you on a
handshake basis.
There have been some discussion
about the changes
in App Engine pricing model.
We're changing the
pricing model.
It's going to be a little more
expensive for people.
We're asking this money of you
because we're offering a
certain amount of reliability.
And in the same way, I can't
just say well, I depend on
that infrastructure.
But you guys are going to mostly
run it for us, right?
Because they understand the
infrastructure and they can
look at it and say, it's got
this much complexity, we've
got our own dependencies.
And we think it can be
available this much
amount of the time.
This many 9's or this much
down time per year.
And we look at what they
offer us and say, we
can work with that.
We'll use your service.
Or if it's below our
threshold, we
say, you know what?
We'd love to use it if you
could bring it up to this
level of reliability.
Can we pay you in internal
currency or favors, or
whatever it is?
And sometimes they say yes and
sometimes they say no.
And the reason that this
is important is that
mathematically, we're
depending on
all of these services.
And you can not be more reliable
than the least
reliable service that
you rely upon.
So we have to make a decision
based on the reliability of
the underlying services
that we rely upon.
And so what's some of the
sources of this unreliability?
Well, this software
is not static.
It's always changing.
There's always bugs
being found.
There's always features
being added.
We're also always worried
about efficiency and
increasing efficiency.
We have our computers.
If we can make a change across
the board that brings 5%
efficiency improvement in this
sub system across all of
Google, that's a lot of spare
computing cycles, that's a lot
of power, that's a lot of money
that we can save that we
can use to use the same
infrastructure to scale
everything else.
So this is software and it
needs to be upgraded.
It can't be like your laptop
where it says, well, I want to
install this software.
Hold on while I reboot.
So we have to get this software
out there into
production while having 24 by 7
service for all these Google
applications.
So we design from the beginning
for in place updates
transparently as possible, which
is to say that there's
an update going on right
now in the background.
We're slowly rolling it out
and you shouldn't notice
anything except that Gmail, all
of a sudden you're Gmail's
chugging along and then
it says, oh wait.
I need to reload.
And you get your mailbox
back again.
And the UI's a little
different.
It wasn't like Gmail was like,
we're going to be down for six
hours while we're doing
an upgrade.
We do this upgrade in place
right up until the moment that
we expose it to you.
Te infrastructure underlying
it works the same way.
When there's a new version of
the story subsystem, we just
say, roll it out slowly in the
background, slowly enough that
the services that are using on
it are engineered to deal with
that unreliability.
But you can't do this with
everything because some
maintenance is too intrusive.
Sometimes it requires intrusive
software work.
You actually have to take down
part of a stack, rework it a
little bit, bring it back up.
Similarly, if they say well, we
want to take down half the
datacenter to rework the power
distribution units.
Fix the generator, oh wait, the
cooling's having problems.
You can't just say like we're
going to do this and hopefully
everything will be all right.
So what we do is we get out our
calendar and we mark out,
and we say, OK, this given
datacenter, we need to do a
bunch of work on it and we do
this on a regular schedule.
And we're going to gang up all
of the really intrusive
disruptive work that we need to
do, put it all together and
say, this datacenter
is going to be out
during this time period.
And there's an interesting
design pattern here, which is
to say that we don't say
that every datacenter--
we're going to try and
keep it up as much as
possible all of the time.
When you start launching a
product at Google, you
understand that the datacenter
the you land in is going to
blink out of existence
for some amount
of time every year.
And what that means is that
you have to be nimble.
You have to be able to say, OK,
when that happens, I need
to be able to serve my user
capacity somewhere else.
I need to do it as transparently
as possible.
This has to be baked into your
application from the beginning
or you're going to take
embarrassing outages every
time this happens.
So speaking of architecting for
datacenter failovers, how
does this apply to App Engine?
Specifically the master
slave configuration
that we launched in.
So I've seen this slide given
a couple other times, so I'm
going to sort of blaze through
it a tiny bit.
So this is a very complicated
App Engine architectural
diagram that are intellectual
property that I'm revealing to
you here for the price
of admission.
Which is that your application
is serving out of datacenter A
and reads and writes are
happening to data store, and
everything's great.
And we are asynchronously
replicating from the data
store in A to the data
store over in B.
And so everything's sort
of well and good.
And then they say, hey,
datacenter A is going to be on
available for time period X.
And we pick a time a little in
advance of time period X.
And if you've launched an
application on master slave,
this should be sort of
familiar to you with
what's going on.
But I'll show you under
the covers.
So we disable writes so that you
can continue reading, but
there's no changes coming
into the data store.
And this is so that we can
engage this bulk data copy
process, synchronizing
datacenter A and datacenter's
B data store.
And once that's done,
we are guaranteed
that A and B are identical.
We can say all right,
we're ready to go.
And we flip the switch
and we move
datacenter B to be the master.
Reads and writes are
happening there.
The direction of replication
is reversed.
And at this point, we can take
datacenter A offline for some
amount of time and they can do
whatever they need to it with
the power and the cooling
and the hey, hey, hey.
And you know, your application
continues to serve.
Other than the fact that with
no further outage other than
the read-only period we just
made you go through.
So that's all well and good,
but it's also not very
complicated.
If this was all that we had to
deal with, they wouldn't need
SREs and I wouldn't have this
job, this very interesting and
well-paying job.
So I want to talk a little bit
about things that happen to us
that we sort of didn't
anticipate.
And there's a bunch of good
stories here, and I really
wish I could tell.
And a lot of them I was like,
how about this one?
And they said, no.
That exposes a little too much
of our infrastructure.
This is what I could get cleared
and it's oh, so good.
All right, so we exposed a
long time ago that Google
doesn't have UPS's in
our datacenters.
We don'y have a big room
full of batteries.
Each server has a small UPS
battery next to it, connected
to it, providing battery back up
in case the power goes out.
And so, here's a server--
simplified--
that is running the
storage process.
And it's accepting writes from
the network and committing
them to disk.
And it's all really good.
But you note that the storage
process is talking to a power
management process.
And you say sort of,
well, why is that?
It's so that we can do this,
which is an amazing
optimization and I really,
really like it.
Which is to say that if the
power goes out, we're running
off of battery.
And rather than doing some kind
of broadcast notification
from a central location that
oh hey, the datacenter has
lost power, the server knows
that as soon as it's happened
that the power's off because
it's running off a battery.
The wall power has gone away.
And the great thing that can
happen is that the storage
process asks the power
management process.
It's been doing this
periodically and it's saying,
what's the state of the
power infrastructure?
And you say, why would
it bother?
It's so it can do this, which is
when the power's out, it'll
say, oh wow.
I shouldn't accept any more
writes from the network.
And the reason it does that is
because we've accepted writes
and they're maybe cached
in memory.
They may be in the application
memory.
They may be in the
kernel memory.
They may be in write
cache on the disk.
The write has not necessarily
been synchronously accepted
from the network all the
way down to the disk.
So we want to buy ourselves
some time to get
that flushed to happen.
Which if it's server is going to
lose power, then we want to
have a guarantee
that we have--
or a high guaranteed
chance that the
data was all committed.
So the storage process says,
I'm not going to accept any
other writes.
And this works beautifully.
So imagine you have a datacenter
that looks like
this with an array
of storage nodes.
And writes are happening
everywhere.
A couple of the servers are
down for maintenance, so
they're denying writes and
everything's happy.
And then the power goes out
and it looks like this.
It's beautiful.
Everybody says, I'm not
accepting writes.
And as quickly as that happens,
all of the services
that were trying to write to
them realize, wow, nothing
here in this datacenter
is accepting writes.
Let me return a deferral back
to the client JavaScript
that's running in the
user's browser.
And they say, hey, we're
having a problem.
Let's try again in a minute.
So the state that the user's
trying to submit isn't lost.
We didn't say, oh, yeah.
We accepted it and
it's all good.
The minute this happens, we can
ripple that error back out
to the user in a way that allows
them to cleanly retry.
It's beautiful.
And of course, I'm telling you
this story because it didn't
work out that way.
Which is to say that the power
management process is talking
to the power supply.
Power supplies are spooky,
spooky analog crap.
And occasionally, the power
management process would talk
to the battery or talk to power
supply and say, so hey,
how's the battery?
And the power supply would
say, there's no battery
attached to me.
Really?
OK.
You know, I thought I just asked
you a minute ago and you
said there was.
But maybe they disconnected
it.
OK, that's fine.
And then if you asked it
again a minute later it
would say, oh, right.
No sorry.
There's a battery in here.
It's sort of like voltage and
charge and general health.
But there was a race condition
in the middle here where the
storage process would ask the
power management process, so
what's the state of the power?
And the power manager process
would say, it's good.
We're up.
We clearly have power.
But I don't have a battery
installed.
Just so you know.
And the power managed storage
process made a decision that
was not actually very good,
which is it decided well, if
there's no battery, I don't
need to keep on
talking to you any more.
That thread that I was running
that was talking to the power
management process, I'm going
to save some CPU by just
shutting that down.
Because there's no point.
If there's no battery when
the power goes out, I'm
just going to crash.
Why should I bother?
You can think about the
consequences of this, which is
to say that the power goes
out and the server keeps
on going yep, sure.
I'll take some writes.
Do whatever you want.
I'll take them into
and continually
call them in memory.
And then we had a power outage
that looked like this, which
is to say that most of the
servers said, oh wait.
I'm not going to accept
any writes.
But a handful of them had
triggered this bug.
And when they triggered
this bug they
continued accepting writes.
And so this was fine because--
well OK, we
went on to the generator.
And that was great.
And the generator came back and
I have another slide of
all green and it's
all fantastic.
And then the generator's turbo
started glowing cherry red.
And the hardware ops guys onsite
said, well, I don't
know what the procedure is for
this, but it looks like it's
about to explode.
And when it's about to explode,
I think we're going
to turn it off.
So they went over and they
hit the big red button.
And they really have a big
red button for this.
And you know, I'm glad they got
to hit it at least once.
And they turned the
generator off.
So we're back on
battery again.
And utility power hasn't
come back on.
So we're in this situation and
all of these servers are
accepting writes and accepting
writes and accepting writes,
and then they all crash.
So that didn't really sort of
work out so well for us.
I'm going to point out that we
didn't have any data loss in
this situation because when the
power went out, we drained
the datacenter of traffic.
We have the ability to globally
redirect traffic away
from that datacenter.
We said, OK, something's
going on.
So user traffic went away.
But there's still some
background processes running
doing batch processing
of various stuff.
Those things are still running
even though the front end
traffic had gone away.
They were happily
writing, happily
writing, happily writing.
And then we lost that
data temporarily
when the servers crashed.
This drastically increased our
return to service time for
this datacenter.
It took it out for much longer
than statistically it takes us
to return a datacenter to
service after we've had a
power outage.
That's no good for us,
so we fixed that.
So we learned some
things from this.
Which is that you can't always
trust your monitoring.
It'll lie to you and sometimes
it'll lie to you
intermittently, which
is awesome.
This is a trust, but verify.
Ronald Reagan's excellent
one quote.
And you say that don't make
any decisions permanently
based on one data point.
And like I said, the system
may lie to you.
And some optimizations
are not worth doing.
It was very nice of the storage
process to say, I'm
going to save you this
fractional amount of CPU by
not running this query to the
power management process.
But it cost us all of this time
in clean up and debugging
and general frustration
afterwards.
So this is a good lesson
for there.
So I've got a quote here from
Clay Caviness, who runs
Google's MacOps organization.
These numbers in here are
about our laptop fleet.
They don't tell you anything
about our production
datacenters.
I'm not disclosing anything
that has not been
tightly held before.
"A large fleet like ours means
that a bug that crops up only
0.5% of the time affects
over 100 people.
It becomes difficult to file
bugs when the "how to
reproduce" section is do
this 25,000 times."
And I tell you this story
because the next story is
really sort of all about that.
So one day somebody's pager
goes off and it
says the big table--
a big table, not the entire big
table, but a table inside
of a big table is gone.
And he comes up online and says,
well, what's going on?
We're serving errors out of
this application now.
And he looks and why
did this go away?
And he looks at the big table
master and he says, oh OK.
It says that there was an RPC to
delete that table from this
server and this user
at this time.
And they went back and looked
at that server.
And that server had recently--
there was a process that had
run by that user on
that server and
it had a stack trace.
And it said function A, function
B, function C,
destroy table.
And they went, huh.
And it was funny because we
looked at the code for
function C.
It never should have called
destroy cable.
So at this point,
we're going, OK.
What's going on?
Is this enemy action?
What the hell?
So this was a language with
virtual message dispatch
unfortunately.
And we pulled that server out of
commission and we put it in
through the equivalent of Google
memtestx86 and after
long enough we found out that oh
hey, if you let it run long
enough under high enough load,
it starts corrupting contents
of memory occasionally.
And as nearest we can tell
what happened here was in
function C there was an index
into whatever function it was
going to call.
Give big table a hug
or something.
And the processor corrupted the
memory just perfectly to
instead of calling that
function, let's call destroy
table instead.
And again, this was no data loss
here because after a big
table is deleted, it's not
instantaneously garbage collected.
We have facilities where we can
go, OK, let's recreate it
at the state of the last--
right before the deletion.
On the other hand, that's not
acceptable to us because the
minute that this happened we
started serving errors out of
that datacenter for
that product.
We're serving 500s or whatever
the error code was or please
try again later, et cetera.
Yeah, it's good times.
It's really good times.
So what did we learn
about this?
Again, trust, but verify.
I have seen every piece of
hardware at Google attempt to
corrupt data.
I'm almost not kidding.
Processors, memory, hard
drives, power supplies,
network switches, network
cables, I have not heard a
story where the dolly that we
use to move machines around or
a bad power cable has corrupted
data, but I wouldn't
be surprised if somebody came
to me and told me a story
where that had happened.
When you have enough
pieces of hardware,
they're out to get you.
I don't believe that there are
bad people, but I believe that
there is actually
bad hardware.
You need checksums. You
need checksums on data
transmission.
Checksums for data at rest.
And verify them.
Because if you transmit the data
and it comes out at the
other end, it's not what you
expected, somewhere in there,
something in there, there's
a bad piece of hardware.
You need to find it and get it
out of your infrastructure as
quickly as possible.
It may be causing data loss,
potential data loss, or
something that you're going
to have recover.
Find these things and
get rid of them.
They are the bad apples.
And when these things happen,
you can't be sure that--
like I said, that story.
Suddenly a big table was
gone and nobody copped
to having done it.
And were we hacked?
Was some disgruntled employee
just doing it?
No.
This is the evidence that if you
give an infinite number of
monkeys a typewriter, one of
them will write Shakespeare.
If you put enough pieces of
Google hardware and you roll
enough dice over days and days
and days, eventually one of
them will spontaneously attempt
to delete your data
out from under you.
So I've told you some stories
about planned maintenance and
unplanned maintenance.
And what we learn here is that
any given datacenter can blink
out of existence or be rendered
unfit for serving.
It doesn't matter that the
datacenter was still there
when we deleted that
big table.
Because at the minute that
that happened, we started
serving errors.
This wasn't App Engine, this
was a different product.
And you need to be able
to deal with that.
There's an unending
list of things.
I mean we haven't even gotten
into like people stealing
fiber optic cable or people
digging up-- accidentally
trenching up fiber
optic cable.
Which is the bane of any
networking company's existence.
And you can attempt to harden
each site to make them
resilient against these
things, but it
doesn't always work.
It doesn't matter how much error
correcting RAM I had in
that machine if the processor
was doing the corruption.
It doesn't matter how many
generators I had if we roll
the dice and eventually
the data
spontaneously gets deleted.
Situations will arise that will
make a mockery of it.
It's like the Maginot Line.
They're just going
to go around it.
And you're going to be like,
oh, well, now I have
to deal with this.
So architecturally, what have
we learned about App Engine
and making it more reliant and
making it more reliable?
And so philosophically, we found
that people through the
ages have the right sort of
instinct for this kind of
thing that we like
to find in SRE.
So here's again, the master
slave datastore.
And I'm not going to go through
a bunch of failure
slides, but we can just talk
about it a little bit.
Which is to say that imagine
this circumstance.
Datacenter A can go
away at any time.
The power can go out and we
can't get it back on in time.
The big tables that we're
relying upon can get
spontaneously deleted and
we can restore it.
But again, that's going to
take some amount of time.
There could be a network
partition that just takes the
datacenter off the map.
And all of these things conspire
that say, OK, well we
can't serve your application
out of here, we
need to move it.
But unfortunately, there's
this little line mark to
asynchronous replication
on there.
That makes it hard for us
because we've committed
certain amounts of data to the
datastore in A and if we
promote B, that data's
not there.
And it's not lost because the
datacenter's going to come
back and we're going to
be able to move it.
Move it back over it, but in
the meantime, if we promote
your B to be serving, all of a
sudden your application has
jumped backwards in time a
couple of minutes for all of
the writes.
And once we do get datacenter
A back online, we say, OK,
here's the uncommitted data.
I can't say to you just like,
oh, we'll shove it into
datacenter B because you may
have rewritten that data.
You may deleted it, whatever.
We have to say, here's your
data, you can decide what to
do with it and we're
going away.
That's not a good
story for you.
That's the kind of thing we're
trying to hide from you and
that's not a good
story for us.
We don't want to spend our
time doing that either.
There's way more interesting
problems to be solving for us.
And like I, you can decide that
OK, what we should do is
armor the sites.
And when we do, when we find
things that-- we find some
kinds of fragility that
we think we can sort
of make less common.
We looked at that and we said,
all right, we can deal with
this kind of thing.
But you can't anticipate
everything.
And really what we've found
out is that you
need to become agile.
You need to be able
to leap around.
Things are going to
come at you like
your Jackie Chan movie.
Things are going to be coming
at you from all directions:
above, behind You know,
things are going to
try and fall on you.
And the best thing you can do is
be able to move quickly, so
that you can deal with while
you see that coming at you,
get out of the way, then figure
out what you do next.
And so we thought about this for
a while and we looked at
sort of the things that
improved inside Google
infrastructure and we said,
what can we do about this?
And the end product is this.
It's the high replication
datastore
configuration to App Engine.
And what it is is we run
multiple datacenters.
And three is not the
actual number.
And we serve your application
out of one of them, but all of
your writes happens
synchronously to all of them.
Before we would do a majority
of them using the Paxos
algorithm, which we talked about
in the datastore talk
and also Leslie Lamport's
paper.
So we commit your writes to a
majority of them before we
return success to you,
your application.
Before you return success to the
user and the web browser.
And the beauty of this is that
if we instantaneously have to
take your traffic away from
datacenter A to datacenter B,
and it really doesn't take too
much more effort for me to do
that then when I just did, then
we can move that without
a read-only period.
We are certain that all of your
data is replicated to a
majority of all of the
other datacenters.
If we missed it for whatever
reason, there's this missed
write replication happening
in the background.
It'll keep all of them up
to date eventually.
And if you have an outage
unplanned or planned, then we
can instantaneously shift the
traffic over and know that
we're not trying to you backup
reads from the offline
datacenter and the missed write
replication is now active.
So we're queuing up
these things once
A comes back online.
Whether it's after scheduled
maintenance or we've drained
traffic away in an emergency,
or the network is
disconnected.
Whatever's happened, we're ready
to handle it when that
datacenter comes back online.
This isolates us from problems
in the underlying storage
stack, which is to say that
if you were serving your
application out of A and
something happens, something
hiccups in that stack.
Remember, we don't run it.
We share it with other people.
And we attempt to isolate it,
but isolation is really hard.
So if something happens, if some
amount of traffic, some
amount of disruption, some bug,
something's going on that
disrupts this situation, the
megastore layer that handles
all the writes down to the
datastore can look at that and
say, you know what?
I'm not actually getting a quick
response to the reads
and the writes out of
my local datastore.
I prefer that one because
it's local.
I don't have to go to another
datacenter, but if that one's
not performing adequately for
me, I'm going to ignore it and
I'm going to commit my writes
over there to the other
datacenters.
Which even though I'm sending
it over the network and
there's the speed of light issue
with how fast it gets
there and how fast it gets back,
it's still better than
waiting several seconds
for the local
storage option to return.
And this goes on the minute that
there's any performance
problems. We are aware of what
that happened and we monitor
it, but I don't have
to do anything.
The system handles
this for me.
In the middle of the night,
right now at Google IO, and it
handles it faster than
I can react.
So we see that the perennial
theme throughout all of this,
is that if you think about
modern thinking and systems
thinking, you need to expect
the unexpected.
And this is really what
SRE tries to do.
Oh right, there's a story
I want to tell you.
All right, so I'll
back up to that.
I heard that big table story.
And again, that wasn't something
that happened to me
about the spontaneously
deleted big table.
And I thought about that and
my relatives will sometimes
say to me, so what exactly is
it that you do all day?
And I thought about that story
and sort of how to
explain it to them.
How would I explain that?
There's a large system.
You could think of it sort
of like a steam engine.
You know, it's very elaborate.
It's stories tall.
I understand most of it.
Some parts of it are fuzzy
around the edge unless I get
close to it.
And we're working on it trying
to keep it working and some
days gremlins just pop out of
the system and do something
really unexpected.
And you chase them off and
you get rid of them.
OK, I'm not likely to see that
exact gremlin again, but maybe
he's got a cousin.
And I should make sure that
he and his cousin
can't come back again.
And every day it's
a new surprise.
So how do you survive
life in production?
And here we see our SRE mascot
fulfilling its intended
purpose in life.
So I made a couple of points to
you earlier on, which is to
say we take these
things as given.
A service running in a given
datacenter can be no more
reliable than the
least reliable
component it utilizes.
We love the SRE teams who run
the infrastructure under us,
but they have outages too.
They're conforming to the SLAs
that they promised us, but
that doesn't mean that there's
not going to be an outage.
And also, that you can rely on
serving your application of a
datacenter, but you have to
handle both scheduled
maintenance and surprises
that will make it
unusable at any time.
If you're designing something
like Google, what are the
design principles
that you need?
So everybody get ready
to take notes.
I'm going to give you away
all of Google's secrets.
So here's what we have found is
the best option if you want
to build a worldwide reliable
set of applications.
Put the application in
multiple datacenters.
You know, basic but many
people get this wrong.
Your datacenters have
to be distributed.
They can't be behind
the same power.
the same network.
They can't be on the
same flood plain.
same fault line.
It doesn't matter if you've
a hundred datacenters.
If they're behind shared
infrastructure like that,
they're all going to
go offline at once.
Be capable of absorbing more
than one failure at a time.
Having two is not enough because
you'll say well, I'm
serving out of here and then oh,
I'm having problems. Let
me move my traffic over here.
Certainly nothing is going to
happen to this datacenter over
here before you get the first
datacenter back online, right?
So be capable of absorbing
more than one
failure at a time.
Because the law of perversity
will make sure that it'll
happen to you.
Write synchronously, don't
write asynchronously.
You will say OK, well I can get
better performance out of
it and it won't be so bad, and
my users will get used to it.
And I'll find ways around it.
We wanted that to be the case.
It doesn't actually work.
There's a ceiling to the
threshold of reliability that
we can offer.
We talked about App Engine
coming out of preview and how
we're now going to have an
SLA for all paid users.
That SLA only applies to high
replication, to apps using the
high replication datastore
configuration.
There's a very specific
reason for that.
There's only so much reliability
we can give you
given the asynchronous
replication.
We try really hard and we're
spending a lot of our time
always trying to improve
these things.
But there's only so
much we can do.
Empower the infrastructure.
Don't make it only manual
intervention
that changes something.
Let the megastore layer, or the
writing layer, make some
interesting decisions about when
to abandon writing to the
local one and write
somewhere else.
Don't have that be permanent.
Like I said, don't make
permanently dangerous
decisions based on anything.
And when there is a problem,
give me the switch that I can
throw that says, move this
traffic from here to here as
quickly as possible, so that I
can return your application to
service and we can all stand
around the problem and go,
huh, we weren't expecting
that to happen.
And also, if you're trying to
build all of this, a bunch of
SREs really doesn't hurt who
done all these things.
So this is a lot of a complexity
and people talk
about the private cloud.
And it's kind of difficult
unfortunately, to do all of
these things on a small scale.
The efficiencies only come when
you're doing them on a
large scale and they're really
difficult and they're really
complicated.
There are unending piles of
bugs that I could tell you
about that we found while
we were debugging our
implementation.
And we have incredibly smart
people anticipating almost all
of these things.
And yet still, we had a lot
of problems. So if you're
interested in building an
application that is scalable
and globally reliable and not
a manual pain in the ass to
administer and failover.
So these are about the things
you have to do.
Or well, we think we have
a better option.
And as people like to say,
it's available right now.
And in fact, more than
be available right
now, it's the default.
As of App Engine 1.5.0, we have
said, high replication is
the default.
You have to manually make a
choice if you want master
slave. We don't want
you to do that.
We are cutting the prices on
master slave. I'm sorry,
cutting the prices on high
replication datastore storage
costs to encourage people.
There are already migration
processes that we have to move
your existing apps from master
slave to high replication.
We are working on
improving those.
That's one of our very top
priorities, and we expect to
have something about that
out very shortly.
Probably on the order of
weeks, not months.
We want you to move your
applications over.
I mean, we really
believe in this.
And I hope that you've taken
away from this, this is all of
the stuff that we learned
about implementing
applications on top of Google's
infrastructure.
And the stuff that we
experienced, taught us what we
needed to do to make
things better.
And we think it works fine if
your application is just
starting out, it's a great
platform to design to if
you've got the next great
idea that you want
to build and monetize.
Or, if you have already got a
tremendous amount of traffic
and you want a better scaling
story then, well, I guess it's
time to send somebody out to
the store to buy a bunch of
more machines and put them
in the datacenter.
And the beauty of this system is
again, the dynamic scaling.
If you get mentioned on Oprah
in the middle of the night
when you're sleeping and all of
a sudden everybody in the
world wants to go to your
website or Justin Bieber
twitters about it, or whatever
it is the kids do these days.
Then App Engine will allow you
to scale this automatically.
You'll be ready for whatever
traffic and all that will
happen is we'll hand
you a slightly
higher bill that month.
Hope you got that monetized
properly.
You know, very enthusiastic
about that.
And with that comes
an army of us.
We've got developers support
people, we've got forums that
you can interact with.
Coming out of preview, we've got
paid support options that
are paid support options for
incidence and ticket responses
that you can take advantage
of if you need this.
We're taking the availability
of this very seriously.
And you get me and my team.
We're follow the sun
on-call coverage.
I don't get woken up in the
middle of the night by pages.
I've got people in other time
zones so that you we can all
be really fresh when we're
working on these problems.
It's not crisis for us.
All of that stuff that I
mentioned, we'll take care of
it for you.
I like that kind of stuff.
I mean I wake up and I go well,
something weird is going
to happen to me today
most likely.
And it'll probably be
pretty exciting.
And I accept that there's
probably something wrong with
me and my team that
like there's
something wrong with us.
But if you don't want to have
to do it, we'll take care of
it for you.
Because you can focus on what
you're excited about, your
domain knowledge, your
application.
On the other hand, if that kind
of stuff does excite you,
I am bound by contract to say we
are hiring for SRE all over
the globe, many projects,
many datacenters--
not datacenters--
many offices.
And there are so many things
that we could teach you.
So if that interests you,
please come talk to me.
So I'm folding up what
I've got to say here.
And I'm going to take a moment
and get very serious.
And so we need to talk a little
bit about transparency.
And I don't need to tell you
all that cloud computing is
big business.
It's not just some website
or people can
dismiss it all they want.
But out there in the customer
area we've got web filings,
and they're taking Fortune 100
companies, their SEC data, and
getting their quarterly
filings into the SEC
on time with them.
That's real money, real jail
time for people for
non-compliance.
Congressional investigations,
et cetera.
We hosted the website for the
recent royal wedding.
This is once in a lifetime, or
well, maybe twice when Harry
gets married.
But whatever.
A unique event on TV,
all eyes on it.
And when Accenture
said, we need an
infrastructure to host it.
They said, App Engine.
So there's a lot of money
coming in to this.
And we know that we have to
treat this very seriously,
treat it as seriously as
you treat your users.
When we have problems, you
need to know about it as
quickly as possible.
You need to understand what
we're doing to make the App
Engine more reliable.
That we're working on
it very seriously.
And the architectural choices
that we've made, the
improvements that we're
working on.
When we start having a problem,
you need to know
about it as quickly
as possible.
And like I said, we've got
communication, we've got all
of these things, SLA for paid
apps on high replication once
we come out of preview.
All of this is saying, we
are going to tell you
what's going on.
When we have problems we'll
give you a detailed
postmortem.
We're bringing out the SREs to
give talks when I don't have
any features tell you other than
you should use HRD and
here are some hilarious
stories.
So the other story about
transparency that's important
is that you need to know when
you're having problems before
your users know that you're
having problems. And those
problems aren't necessarily all
connected to App Engine's
infrastructure.
They could also be related
to high load that your
applications are experiencing,
or a new piece of code.
And the story for monitoring App
Engine applications hasn't
historically been great.
That's true for most cloud
applications honestly.
And this is something that we
knew that we need to improve
if you're going to actually,
trust us to say we're as
available as we are and give
us your money, give us your
trust, give us your data.
So Alan Green, an SRE engineer
out of the Sydney office has
been working on improving the
monetary story for App Engine
applications.
And I'm going to turn this over
to him, so that he can
tell you all about what
he's been working on.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN GREEN: Hi.
So Michael's been telling you
about how Google looks after
the App Engine platform.
And a key part of that is
our monitoring tools.
So for App Engine we're
monitoring thousands and
thousands of statistics about
all of the components that
makeup App Engine.
And we're able to spot problems
and hopefully, find
and fix them before your
apps even notice.
So I'm going to cover the
monitoring API that is going
to trust tester today.
I guess the question is,
why do you need to
monitor your apps?
Because this team of Google
SREs looking after the
platform and if you're confident
in their ability to
keep they platform running,
why do you even need to
monitor your own apps.
The answer is, for many simple
apps, you don't need to
monitor them.
They're so simple and they use
such a small fraction of App
Engine's capabilities that so
long as the platform is
stable, they're going
to keep running.
But for more complex apps, the
kinds of apps that a business
might depend upon for critical
functions, there's some
reasons why you might monitor.
So first the reason is it gives
you insight into the
running of the platform.
So say datastore latency
increases slightly and starts
to get to the point where it's
affecting your customers.
It would be good to know that
before your customers
start to call you.
Another reason is so that you
can get insight into your own
application.
And a good example of
that is mail quotas.
So if app is sending mail, you
set a budget for it and App
Engine lets you send mail up
until you hit that budget.
But if you getting close to that
budget it would be good
to know because when you
hit it, it stops.
And if you know, you can do
something about it in advance.
And finally, you need to monitor
because you're on the
internet and every crazy
person with a computer
can see your app.
So Michael mentioned before
gri.pe, G-R-I-dot-P-E, who
were mentioned on Oprah and
they're traffic graph kind of
was going along flat at just a
couple of requests per second.
And within a few minutes,
they're all of a sudden
serving 250 requests
per second.
And it'd be good to know when
something like that happens to
your app, right?
So how many people here actually
use a monitoring tool
in their organisation?
A few of you, right.
So you'll know all this.
But a monitoring tool is a
program that sits there and it
pulls the things that
it monitors.
They can be anything from
hardware devices to databases
to servers, you're
own software.
But the important thing is that
when something goes wrong
it tells you about it and lets
you look at the history of
what's happened to
the service.
So there's quite a number of
different monitoring tools,
but three of the big ones out
there are Nagios, Zabbix and
HP OpenView.
You might have heard
those names before.
What this API does is lets you
integrate your App Engine app
into the monitoring tool.
So that you can see it the same
way you see everything
else in your service.
So driving down a little bit
more into the API, here are
the things need to
know about it.
It's experimental.
We're putting this out there
so that we can get some
feedback about whether we're
providing the right
information about your apps to
you, whether we're providing
it in a good form.
The information that it exposes
is all the stuff
that's currently on
the dashboard.
So just flick over and have a
look at this app's dashboard.
So the number of requests per
second coming in, all this
good stuff.
How many instances you're
currently running.
How much memory you're
currently using.
All of that now comes out
through the monitoring API, as
well as all of the
quota information
that's on the dashboard.
Because it's a standard API,
you can use the Google API
Explorer to investigate
the API.
So there's two methods
we're providing.
One is apps.list to list all of
the applications that you
have. And it's also queued so
let's try to execute this.
We see the results down here.
Oh, we need to be
authenticated.
We must have--
there we go.
These are all of the
applications that this user is
allowed to see that this user
is an administrator of.
So let's just take
one of these.
And look at the counters.
We call them counters, but
it's just the statistics.
The reason for that is the
most interesting ones are
usually just simple counters.
And then the results
come back.
Lovely JSON list. We
can skip down to an
interesting one here.
How many memcache calls
have been made.
And today, this apps done
486,274 so far.
So that's the form of API
in just two calls.
Great.
If you are programming to it,
here's an example in Python.
Typical Google API.
So you get your credentials,
you go and ask for details
about the service.
In this case, App Engine
monitoring version alpha 1.
And then you can do things
with the API.
So list all of the apps and then
list all the counters.
OK.
So that's that API.
Very simple.
Let's dive into an example.
I built an app here.
This is why they don't let SREs
write user facing code.
So very simple app.
There's three URLs.
There's slash here, which
is the home URL.
You can write some more news or
you can view news in a way
that allows you to
page through.
OK, so let's say you've got
all of this monitoring
integrated, everything's happy,
it's serving away.
And then one night, your pager
actually goes off.
And it says, excuse me, there's
a lot of CPU usage all
of a sudden.
So you jump in to Zabbix and you
have a look at the graphs.
This red line here is
the alerting level.
So if CPU usage goes over this
line for more than a few
samples, it will
sound an alert.
And you can see here that CPU
usage was pegging along at
under a thousand mega cycles
per minute per second for
quite a long time.
And then all of a sudden, it's
jumped up and it's now using
33,000 mega cycles per second.
Which is a lot of CPUs.
So when something like this
goes wrong and CPU usage
spikes like this, then either
something's changed in the
code or you're getting some
different stimulus to the
application.
And so the next graph you might
want to look at then is
how much traffic are we
getting on each of the
different paths coming in
to the application.
This red line here is requests
to the homepage.
And you can see they're
pegging along pretty
consistently at 11 or 12
requests per second.
But then, just lately we've
started getting requests in
for slash news, which
is different.
That's a bit suspicious.
Then we can dive down and have
a look at underneath the
application what API
calls it's making.
This graph is showing the number
of calls per second to
the datastore in the green line
and to mencache in the
purple line there.
And memcache, it's a bit spiky,
but it's generally
doing somewhere between 10
and 20 calls per seconds.
That's all good.
And the datastore is
doing very few
calls until just recently.
So that looks like it might
be the problem.
And so let's put together what
we've discovered through the
monitoring APIs so far.
We've got a massive
increase in CPU.
Massive increase in
datastore usage.
No increase in memcache usage,
and a little bit of extra
traffic coming in on one path.
That would suggest to me that
that one path that's serving a
tiny little bit of traffic is
serving it uncached, but
instead going straight to the
datastore and doing something
very complex.
not actually caching
the result.
And in fact, because I wrote
this dodgy app, I know that's
exactly what's happening.
Possible solutions here is find
what it is that's sending
traffic to your app and modify
your code to proper use
memcache for that URL.
So that's pretty much the
monitoring API, what it is,
and how do to use it.
It exposes dashboard stats
compatible with pretty much
any monitoring tool.
They all require a little bit of
stitching up to make it all
code together.
It's powered by App Engine
because it turns out that if
you want to write--
at Google, if you want to write
a distributed app that
works across multiple
datacenters, is highly
reliable and available,
App Engine is a
great way to do that.
And we have a Trusted Tester
program for this.
If you're monitoring currently
or thinking about monitoring
and are interested in joining
up, you can go to this short
URL or you can come talk to
us after the presentation.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL HANDLER: All right, so
we're about to fold it up
here, and just so you know where
you were in case you
fell asleep.
This is Life in App Engine
Production Google IO 2011.
I'm Michael Handler, that was
Alan Green giving you the
extent of the monitoring demo.
You can talk about
this, please give
us feedback on this.
I'd love to see what
you thought.
The Trusted Tester API, we're
definitely enthusiastic about
getting people into that
program and learning
some more about it.
There's been some really
interesting talks that
unfortunately, you have to go
back in time to see them.
But I've got a link to one
that's incredibly relevant.
If you want even more
architectural details of the
higher application datastore
configuration versus the
master slave datastore
configuration, Alfred Fuller
and Matt Wilder, Matt's another
SRE on my team, they
gave a talk earlier today
called More 9's Please.
Under the Covers of the High
Replication Data Store.
They've got animated diagrams
in their PowerPoint.
It's fantastic.
I thoroughly recommend
you watch the video.
So we've actually run the clock
out a little bit, so I'm
not going to take any
questions here.
But Alan and I are going
to be waiting outside.
We'll take some questions
out there.
And we might have some of the
other App Engine developers
and SREs around if you wanted
to ask questions about
production.
Thank you so much for coming
and enjoy the rest of IO.